the pink house on cooler street
sounds like any other family home
inside three boys and one girl race to
get ready for school
and there are lots of things to brush
and tie
before the school bell rings
are you looking forward to school
but there's someone missing in their
house in the city of port elizabeth
their mother bella has died of covid
and their father has left the scene
they're orphans now in the care of their
frustrated
23 year old cousin would you
choose to be doing this do you want to
be doing this
no i don't want to
i don't want you why is that
[Music]
16 years old amioli is 11
and twins oi and ai are nine
and they find themselves like many other
children
in a very difficult position did you
know
bella well they're the kids mum yes they
did everything that we needed to
provide is it difficult to go on
without her
after school the children play ball
games on the street
before they tackle their homework at the
table but they know they're going to
have to do it on their
own
[Music]
community leaders here in the eastern
cape told us
thousands of children have lost their
parents or primary caregivers
to the virus and the consequences are
usually severe
when bella died her children lost their
main source of financial support
[Music]
[Music]
the children have an uncle called
it's a painful situation nobody knew
this
is going to be ravaging us like this
no one reverend kakia has lost
three sisters including bella to covert
19
and it's also claimed the life of his
wife
they were buried at this cemetery in
port elizabeth
and the pastor wanted to show us bella's
grave
but neither he nor the caretakers who
run this place
could find it the graveyard
has grown dramatically since his loved
ones were
interred do you remember how you felt
at the time i would not understand why
is it happening to me
alone what is it that i have done
to deserve this but there are things
there are questions that cannot be
answered
in the side of the world they will be
answered
hence i always say to to when i preach i
want to go to heaven and ask
jesus personal one-on-one
why was this allowed to happen to us
the pastor along with several relatives
spent
hours at the cemetery searching for
their loved ones headstone
the caretakers come back with a bundle
of paperwork and he's pointed the family
in the right direction at least i think
they're closer now to finding
bella's gravesite but it isn't easy
eventually they found her final resting
place
and the pastor placed a stone on her
grave
how does it feel to to be here now i'm
just holding my tear
i'm just holding my tears i don't want
to cry
but it's not a a nice experience
for the residents of this region the
experience has been shocking
and traumatic more people in the eastern
cape
have died from covert 19 than anywhere
else
in the country
and young people will be forced to live
with its legacy
in a world without adults soup kitchens
for children
are required and we found one handing
out noodles
and watermelon in a township in port
elizabeth
the youngsters both orphans and members
of vulnerable families
were grateful but the organizers were
sad
because this is all they can do to help
them
john sparks sky news in the eastern cape